confucius says that you have two lives
and the second one begins when you
realize you only have one
when and how did your second life begin
it's a very deep question i think uh
most people who are past a certain age
have had this
feeling or phenomenon where they've gone
through most of life a certain way and
then
gotten to a certain stage and then had
to make some pretty big changes
and i'm definitely also in that boat i
think for me it was i struggled for a
lot of my life to
have certain material and social
successes and when i achieved those
material and social successes or at
least beyond the point where they didn't
matter as much to me anymore i realized
that my peer group and a lot of the
people who were around me
and the people who had achieved those
similar successes and were on their way
to achieving more and more successes
just didn't seem all that happy
and uh and in my case there was
definitely hedonic adaptation i'd very
quickly get used to anything
so
let me to the conclusion which seems
trite uh that happiness is internal uh
and so then that set me on a path of
starting to work more on my internal
self uh and realizing that all real
success is internal and has very little
to do with external circumstances but
one has to do the external thing anyway
that's how you're biologically hardwired
so it's it's clipped so you can just
turn it off you have to do it and you
have to have your own life experience
that then brings you back onto the
internal path
so for me it was just
basically
getting what i wanted was the problem
very related to that daniel d 161 asks
do you feel an inner urge to know
yourself fully and has your worldly
success satisfied this urge
i would say
yeah i absolutely do have an inner urge
to know myself fully
and if anything the worldly success has
taken has has taken me further away from
satisfying that urge
the more worldly success you have
the more your ego gets built up the more
fearful you might be of losing it all
the more you care what other people
think the more you have to lose the more
you get caught up in this dream of who
you think you are
and so i think worldly success actually
hurts
if from a young age you know that you
want to
know yourself and discover yourself much
better if you have that foresight or
insight at an early age
then material success will actually take
you away from it
uh i'm not christian but there is that
famous line in the bible that you know
jesus says easier than
you know a camel to go through the eye
of a needle than for a rich man to get
into heaven and i think i understand
what he means
i actually don't think happiness is its
own thing i think a lot of what we think
of as happiness is actually just
pleasure
it's physical pleasure either from oh
that tasted good or it might be
momentary pleasure from oh she loves me
or he loves me
but i think true happiness comes out of
peace
and peace
comes out of many things but it comes
out of fundamentally understanding
yourself it comes from looking inside
yourself and understanding how much of
what
you're reacting to or emotional
reactions or attachment self-inflicted
suffering it's desire that you have for
things that you probably shouldn't care
that much about
there's a great line that my brother
kamal quoted in his book here's a great
book called uh love yourself like you're
like your life depends on it and another
one called live your truth he's actually
the philosopher in the family i'm just
the amateur but uh he had a great line
in there where he said i i once asked
him a monk
um
you know uh
what what is your secret to to peace and
happiness and the monk said i say yes to
everything that happens i say yes
and that's very hard for us to imagine
because in life we're used to fighting
for everything we're used to getting
whatever we want we're used to reacting
we're used to immediately saying that
stinks that's good that's bad we're used
to constantly judging things and the act
of judging something separates you from
that thing and over time as you
judge you invariably judge people you
judge yourself you separate yourself
from everything and then you end up
lonely and that feeling of disconnection
and loneliness is what eventually leads
to suffering and then you struggle you
resist against the world the way it is
and that that
is what your ego does it helps you
operate in the real world by resistance
against against things you don't like
and that is a source also of a lot of
unhappiness so i actually think
happiness is the absence of suffering it
comes from peace
and that comes from just being very
careful about desire judgment and
reactions realizing that you don't
really need something anymore that that
something is not important to you
so to get very practical about it i have
a whole series of tricks that i use to
try and be happier in the moment and i
started doing these a few years ago and
at first they were silly and difficult
and required a lot of attention but now
some of them have become second nature
and i think
doing them i've just
religiously i've managed to increase my
happiness level quite a bit
the obvious one is meditation
and insight meditation so working
towards a specific purpose on it which
is to try and understand how my mind
works but then just being very aware in
every moment so if i catch myself
judging somebody then uh i can stop
myself and say well what's the positive
interpretation of this so
i used to get annoyed about things now i
always look for the positive side of it
and it used to take a rational effort it
used to take a few seconds for me to
come up with a positive
now i can do it sub second my brain is
trained to do it automatically
similarly i try you know there are other
hacks i can try to get more sunlight on
my skin that's an easy cheap one look up
and smile
tell yourself tell your friends that
you're a happy person then you'll be
forced to be uh to conform to it you'll
have the consistency bias you have to
live up to it your friends will expect
you to be a happy person
these are little hacks i mean they add
up over time they're not going to pull
you out of a severe depression that's a
much deeper more difficult thing but if
you're just trying to upgrade your
happiness ever so slightly
you can do it
another hack would be uh just any time
you catch yourself desiring something
say is it really that important to me
that i'd be unhappy unless this goes my
way and you're gonna find the vast
majority of things it's just not true
i think dropping caffeine made me
happier it made me more of a stable
person working out every day makes me
happier
if you have piece of body you'll have
it's much easier to have peace of mind
so there's there's lots and lots of
these things that can go on this could
be a full podcast
but i'm still discovering and learning
these things myself
i think it would be interesting to maybe
catalog them
but i suspect that a lot of them are
deeply deeply personal
if i step back for a second and answer
the question properly the most important
trick i think to being happy is to
realize that happiness is a skill that
you develop and a choice that you make
you choose to be happy and then you work
at it it's just like building muscles
it's just like losing weight it's just
like succeeding at your job it's just
like learning calculus you decide it's
important to you you prioritize it above
everything else you read everything on
the topic and then you work at it
and again i think the buddhists have
done a lot of good work on this i don't
think modern science is good answers
here i think the modern world is
actually really bad the modern world is
full of distractions things like twitter
and facebook are not making you happy
they're actually making you unhappy
you're essentially playing a game that's
created by the creators of those systems
and yes it can be a useful game once in
a blue moon but most the time you're
just wasting your time you're engaging
in envy dispute and
resentment
comparison
jealousy
anger about things that frankly just
don't matter
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you